[Music]
foreign
oh
what the [__] is this
[Music]
foreign
and there's a [__] bone cutter they
crying yourself I don't care what the
[__] thing is called that's in there
they're just just blame me I'm not gonna
touch nothing
[Music]
hello Mateo
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life
John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much time do I have
months at best I still have a lot of
work that needs to be done
[Music]
foreign
you know
anything I have not provided is your
anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
of all the men to cheat you picked John
Cramer please don't hesitate
place a big enough piece of your
cerebral tissue into the glass enzyme
tank this will save your life
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign